il est 13 heures ce vendredi 9 janvier
à châteauroux comme ailleurs les
français vivent tant directs la
troisième journée des attentats
au même moment un élève du lycée blaise
pascal quitte les courts cet adolescent
de 15 ans que nous appellerons thomas
vient récupérer sa moto un groupe
d'élèves l'attend dans le local à vélos
plusieurs d'entre eux frappe thomas
l'agression va durer plusieurs minutes
d'après nos sources l'altercation a pour
origine une conversation qu'ils aient
lieu sur facebook la veille de
l'agression le jeudi 8 janvier thomas
affiche son soutien au mouvement je suis
charlie voici ce qu'il se serait dit par
la suite
la liberté d'expression c'est gagner
dans le sang en 1789 on fait tout ça
pour douze morts alors qu'il ya des
milliers de morts en palestine et
personne ne fait rien pour eux si vous
n'êtes pas d'accord avec les principes
de la république
vous avez qu à les vivre dans un état
islamique thomas aurait alors été menacé
avant d'être agressé le lendemain trois
élèves du lycée ont reconnu les faits
nous avons décidé de rencontrer les
parents de l'un d'entre eux tout en
conservant leur anonymat
bonjour madame vous êtes madame clément
moreau choses en l'état
au premier passage je dors pas je mange
pas c'est pas bien dit que ce qu'ils
attendent de mauvaise foi pour un
touriste pas possible à garer votre les
jeunes arrivent ça et si pas la question
de la fal pas c'est pas la question de
ce qui s'y passait la bague il s'assied
et et autres lits dans les hôpitaux
le père de la victime nous a quant à lui
confié sa colère blessé son fils n'est
pas retournée en cours durant tout un
mois
cette agression n'est pas un acte isolé
l'éducation nationale a recensé 200
incidents au lendemain des attentats
celui ci est l'un des plus graves la
ministre n'a donc pas tardé à venir sur
place quel est donc ce malaise qui gagne
l'éducation nationale quelle est la
responsabilité de l'école des
enseignants des parents comment
enseigner la liberté d'expression et les
valeurs de la république pour comprendre
nous avons choisi de donner la parole à
une ancienne professeur du lycée blaise
pascal à une représentante de parents
d'élèves et une sociologue de
l'éducation l'après charlie a donné lieu
une surenchère une surenchère de laïcité
interprété comme une modalité défensive
et non pas comme la construction de
vivre ensemble personne ne peut
ressortir comme si rien ne s'était passé
je pense que ça a révélé c'est quand je
dis révélé c'est vraiment ça fait
ressortir les choses et chacun est
obligé de se rendre compte que il ya du
mal être il ya du mal vivre et qui a
besoin de mettre de l'huile dans les
rouages et de se comprendre à tous les
niveaux c'est pas que le ministère avec
une note signée pink sheet mariano 1
ça fera rien agnès rhône hold on a
claqué la porte de l'éducation nationale
il y a quatre ans enseignante des
filières professionnelles durant vingt
ans à blaise pascal
elle raconte avoir quitté un système à
bout de souffle de ne plus avoir
l'impression de faire de l'enseignement
et de l'éducation
beaucoup d'assistance sociale de
parallèlement à ça j'avais des
obligations de résultats et des
obligations de résultat qui était à mon
goût non adaptées aux élèves que j'avais
devant moi
le lycée blaise pascal n'est pas classée
au réseau d'éducation prioritaire
ici il y à 11 cents élèves répartis sur
des filières générale et professionnelle
les taux de réussite au bac sont très
disparates 95 % pour le bac général 55
pour le bac pro dans l'établissement
chacun son bâtiment
thomas en seconde générale suivi ses
cours dans le bloc principal et ses
agresseurs présumés en seconde
professionnelle dans le bâtiment à
pour apaiser les tensions le lycée
blaise pascal a organisé une semaine
républicaine et l'idée mélanger les
filières pour instaurer le dialogue on
vous distribuerez un questionnaire pour
revenir un petit peu sur les événements
qui s'en passer au niveau national
également donc au niveau local les
règles du débat ne pas dépasser les
limites de la liberté d'expression
est ce que vous trouvez que c'est que ça
pose pas un problème que parce que
quelqu'un a émis une opinion devient une
des saints ils soient obligés d'être
protégée parce qu'il est bon c'est pas
n'importe qui condamne un dessin l'on
parle monsieur la liberté d'expression
c'est peut-être un droit mais c'est pas
un droit fondamental
convenez sein droit français oui mais
c'est un de mes agents sont nés en
france et la caricature l'aitf en france
et en france ils sont pas sortis on
savait qu'on allait parler un petit peu
des deux lignes de charlie hebdo ça
allait poser un petit peu pas des
problèmes et ça allait permettre de
raviver un petit peu certaines tensions
mais je comprends aussi que les que les
jeunes de confession musulmane se
sentant qui peut toucher ou affectées
sortie de a
mais s'ils s'en sortir non non non non
mais moi je respecte tout à fait ce que
l'on m'a aimée 10 10 mais c'est pas ça
c'est tuer des personnes dont leur avis
aux joueurs à la tendance et tu es
vraiment préparé dès janvier oui m et
vidéos d'enfants en palestine qui sont
sur une plage qui conduisait mais on est
en france et est ce que quelqu'un est
venu plus risqués a dit je suis pas déçu
moi je suis prof d'économie gestion
notamment de marketing dont c'est vrai
que ces notions là ce ne sont pas des
notions que j'aborde régulièrement
donc c'est vrai qu'on a tous un peu
révisé pour être plus à l'aise sur cette
notion là mais on se rend compte qu'on
me demande de plus en plus aux
enseignants et que le métier change de
plus en plus tant que au fond
l'éducation nationale ne se questionnera
pas sur les modalités de recrutement et
se bornera à penser que un bon prof
d'anglais c'est quelqu'un qui parle très
bien anglais sans tester aucune de ses
compétences de type social sociologique
et sait que ce sera très difficile aux
enseignants de réagir
or asséné par le haut des valeurs qui
sont pas celles de la société dans son
ensemble
ça ne peut que se traduire par au fond
un sentiment un sentiment d'injustice
une suspicion et loyauté qui portent
évidemment sur saint cyr certains et pas
sur d'autres
et du coup ça peut pas être investis par
les élèves alors bien sûr ils ont ils
ont parlé quand leur a demandé de parler
pas trop fort et surtout pas pendant la
minute de silence
voilà la mise en place de la semaine
républicaine au lycée blaise pascal et
une mesure d'urgence absolue
qu'en est il des cours d'éducation
civique au programme dans tous les
établissements scolaires français avant
qu'il n'en garde des traces à vie
agissons au lycée pierre et marie curie
de châteauroux c'est terminale es
abordant ce début d'année la thématique
du cyberharcèlement si vous avez
peut-être lu la charte de fonctionnement
de votre compte facebook
je pense que tout le monde vous l'avez
lu à en créer votre compte voilà des
élèves ont tous les quinze jours une
heure d'éducation civique juridique et
sociale c'est suffisant pour mener le
programme on va dire oui mais en pole
toujours faire plus un vire pour
toujours faire plus c'est vrai il ya une
une contrainte dans le temps dans
l'école nous faut tout gérer très vite
faut tout faire très vite
il ya un manque de moyens évident et ce
qui fait que nombre de choses ne sont
pas traitées ou nombre de choses sont
mangés on les mange pour récupérer de
l'anglais du français des maths
n'apporte samuel et ses amis sont en
terminale s
ces élèves ont tous étaient très choqués
par les attentats dès le premier jour
samuel a lancé l'idée d'un rassemblement
à châteauroux mais dans leur lycée
l'émotion a parfois fait obstacle au
dialogue et les professeurs qui n'ont
pas parlé parce que ça les intéressait
pas ou qu'ils sentaient pas concernés
mais parce qu'ils savaient pas forcément
comment aborder le sujet ou alors ils
sentaient pas compétent à ce niveau là
on
ressenti un peu un manque d' aide de
notre établissement mais pas vraiment
l'établissement puisqu'il a un peu
dirigé par les hautes instances du
ministère de l'éducation nationale et du
coup c'est peut-être pour ça que nos
projets ont vu le jour aujourd'hui cette
bande de potes a décidé de créer un
journal lycéen
certains n'ont jamais lu un charlie
hebdo mais le symbole reste fort reste à
cogiter sur la première une du journal
une caricature forcément en dehors du
lycée il y à d'autres initiatives des
initiatives pour des élèves plus jeunes
nous sommes au collège stanislas
limousin certains de ces enfants iront
peut être un jour au lycée blaise pascal
vous mais l'entrée s'il vous plaît
aujourd'hui c'est un cours un peu
spéciale pour ses cinquièmes la classe
reçoit la ligue des droits de l'homme
c'est important de leur apporter des
pistes de réflexion pour qu'il puisse
penser par eux mêmes surtout réfléchir
sur des thèmes de société et d'actualité
expliquer aussi ce que dit la loi en
matière de liberté et sachez quand même
que pour ses limites diffamation
incitation à la haine raciale etc
tous les médias sont tous les supports
sont sont concernés
c'est utile monsieur par exemple un jour
on est sur les réseaux sociaux on veut
posté quelque chose on ne sait pas
forcément ce qu'on va mettre
il ya des heures d'instruction
ces vies mais ce que nous disent souvent
soit les principaux soit les professeurs
c'est le regard extérieur que nous on
apporte enfin la parole extérieur à
l'institution con que nous on peut on
peut apporter renforcent quelque part
lors leur douleur leur propre discours à
eux
oui il ya d'autres gens en dehors de
l'école qui font ce même travail serait
ce l'une des clés des sanctuariser
l'école retour au lycée blaise pascal ou
plutôt aux alentours du lycée
l'établissement se trouve tout près du
quartier saint-jean ici le taux de
pauvreté est l'un des plus élevés de la
région
tous les mardis et les jeudis les
animateurs de la maison de quartier
s'occupe d'enfants du primaire à la
sortie des cours des jeunes comprennent
pas forcément ce qui se passe où je
crois qu'il le comprenne entretenu entre
guillemets d'une mauvaise manière
peuvent dire certes des fois dire des
choses des choses graves
mais plus je pense par ignorance on est
là voilà pour leur apporter donc
certains éléments et leur expliquer les
droits qu'on a un sur trois les
principes de libre et la de liberté
d'expression qu'est ce qu'il ya derrière
qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire ici qu'est ce
qu'on peut éviter qu est-ce qu on peut
pas faire venir voir après le goûter
place au soutien scolaire auprès du
travail ok on y va c'est parti cette
association oeuvre aussi pour
l'épanouissement des jeunes
pas simple lorsque l'actualité vient
rattraper le quotidien ici aussi les
attentes a laissé des traces certains se
sont sentis stigmatisés
je pense quand on travaille sur le fait
voilà deux de se sentir en fait voilà on
a on est français on peut être français
musulmans chrétiens juifs même ne pas
avoir de religion mais on est français
avant tout en fait donc je pense que la
société ait quoi que ce soit à l'école
que ça soit ça soit donc de hausse dans
le dos l'autre maison de quartier faire
en sorte voilà que les gens ils sentent
ils faisant partie d'un même pays et je
pense que c'est plus et c'est ça qui va
nous aider à avancer je pense ce qui me
semble important c'est que ce slogan
parce qu maintenant je suis charlize de
devenir un slogan cdc de réfléchir
qu'est ce qui lie à derrière et
peut-être transformer les rapports
humains transformés et favoriser le
beaucoup plus de tolérance entre eux
entre les gens et c'est vrai que sa part
aussi de ses réflexions elle mérite
quand même d'être développée au auprès
des jeunes donc l'école est un moyen
mais pas que au lycée blaise pascal la
vie a repris son cours
les épreuves du bac se profile déjà
thomas est désormais inscrit dans un
autre établissement ses trois agresseurs
présumés ont été exclu définitivement du
lycée deux d'entre eux ne sont plus
scolarisés depuis près de deux mois